good afternoon everyone welcome to the
2011 Nyquist lectureship my name is
Zhang Han I'm the chair of an electrical
engineering department the Nyquist or a
Harry Nyquist lectureship is named in
honor of one of our distinguished alumni
Harry Nyquist who graduated or received
his PhD in 1917 and he had made really
fundamental foundational contribution to
the field of Electrical Engineering on
the backside of this pamphlet II you
there's a his bio I'm not going to
repeat but in one of the citations a
citation is said that his work in
thermal noise analysis data transmission
and they later that was developed into
Shannon Nyquist theorem as well as his
study of the stability of control system
in a negative feedback and that became
Nyquist criteria also for those of us
who are electrical engineers these are
very very well-known in the foundations
so in 1969 he was awarded the National
Academy of Engineering so forth founders
medal in recognition of his many
fundamental contribution to engineering
and this lectureship is in honor of him
and I should also emphasize this
lectureship was made possible through a
generous gift from another alumni
engineering alumni jay rubber man jr.
and he and his wife and this is a man
are with us today he is a class of 1951
and currently he is a chairman and the
CEO of EGA electric installation company
and founded in 1899
so it's entering the third century for
this company and he over the past
decades he is a very strong supporter
for yeah School of Engineering and
Applied Science as well as the
Department of Electrical Engineering
he has just give a few example he
supported that J Robert Mann Center for
electronic system design and for the
faculty Innovation Fund for electrical
engineering as well as more recently a
very nice Student Center and this is the
tha rubber man junior engineering
Student Center
normally for this this type of symposium
we have reception at a very nice Center
but for today because of there's a
renovation work so later the reception
will be outside the Davis auditorium so
this is by way of announcement and he is
a recipient so mr. Mann is the recipient
of the Yale medal and this is year's
highest award to honor outstanding
individual service to the University and
we just want to express our appreciation
for his longtime support for today's
speaker I feel I'm taking half of the
talk now so today's speaker it's an
honor and a pleasure to have a professor
John Rogers in here with us
he's from University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign for those of you who
are at the lunch
forgive me I'm just repeating some of
his his career he grew up in Houston and
went to UT Austin I received a
bachelor's degree in 89 so you can get
his age and then United then he went
down to MIT and received PhD in physical
chemistry in 95 and after that he spent
two years as a junior fellow at hover
and then
decided to try something different and
spend five years at a bail lab the first
three years according to him was really
a marvelous time and the second the
second half the the latter two years in
2000 in 2002 that supposed bubble era so
that made him decide to try the academia
academia since 2002 and the currently he
is the lead Jeff Lori founder chair in
engineering at Illinois and his primary
appointment is the department of
material science and engineering his
research has been in the materials and
the novel material patterning and make
him photonic electronic devices and
currently with the emphasis in the
bio-inspired system there are many a
publication more than three hundred
papers I should add that I often tell my
students that Professor Rogers
publication has uplifted that the
quality of the entire standard of
publication in physical science I'm sure
later he will show some some example of
his research result he is a fellow of a
many society I triple EMRs APs and AAS
and he is a member of the National
Academy of Engineering and the 2009 he
received the MacArthur Fellowship and
most recently lemelson-mit prize in 2011
so today he's going to tell us about the
future of electronics and so the title
ok still the same title yes so a
situation curvy future for electronics
from neural interface to eyeball cameras
yeah welcome John okay all right thanks
very much for that kind introduction
it's a real honor to be here and have a
chance to give this particular lecture
ship so I thank John and also Larry for
the role that they played in the
selection process thanks also to the
Mann family for making this possible I'm
listening to all the wonderful things
you've done for Yale and I'm thinking we
need more alumni like that at Illinois
we're very very lucky to have you
I'll tell you about some research that
we've been doing at Illinois over the
last five six seven years depending on
when you find a start date and a future
of electronics that we think could be
interesting in terms of its ability to
open up new areas of application and
design engineering opportunities or
electronics in a couple of areas that we
think could be a broad societal value if
we're able to successfully do this sort
of thing and so as I mentioned the title
is the stretchy curvy future for
electronics and we're interested in bio
integrated devices like neural
interfaces and bio-inspired device
designs like electronic eyeball type
cameras and so I stepped you through
some of the the motivation the concepts
and materials that kind of worked well
for us in this space and then give you a
couple of specific examples of classes
of devices that we think are pretty
promising but I'll just say at the
outset this is very much kind of a
qualitative type of talk and there's not
a tremendous amount of technical detail
so you know if you're interested in more
information and I would like to talk
further be happy to do that after the
after the seminar so I'll start with the
motivation give you a perspective of how
this future of electronics sort of
interfaces and intersects with the more
traditional one the classes the
materials mechanics design concept
assembly techniques really sort of
manufacturing approaches that that are
valuable sort of in an AV but enabling
component of that class of devices and
talk about brain surgery and epidermal
electronics before a live demo so if you
think about the future of electronics
most people think about and most people
are working on a development pathway
that was really established in the very
early days after integration at the
invention of the integrated circuit by
Jack Kilby at Texas Instruments way back
here in the early 70s and it's a
development pathway in which the number
of transistors per processor is doubling
every 18 months roughly and that was a
trend first spotted by Gordon Moore and
it's really remained true throughout the
development up at to modern times and
that's really a spectacular engineering
achievement to sort of stay on that kind
of scaling pathway and because the
overall processor size is not changing
very much what this means is that by
increasing the number of transistors per
die you're really increasing their
individual sizes and that is powerful
because it allows you to pack more and
more switching elements and therefore
functionality per processor and the
other advantage of small is that for
transistors that means they can operate
at lower voltages and switch at higher
speeds so the kind of problem that's
being addressed by the research and
development piece that's driving this
development pathway is you know
encapsulated by the statement that
transistors are never small enough
they're never fast enough and you ever
have enough of them and there are all
kinds of interesting challenges in
material science manufacturing
Electrical Engineering physics that are
needed to maintain this kind of scaling
pathway and I think that will remain a
really compelling direction for research
and for the future of consumer
electronics into the foreseeable future
at least another 10 years of this looks
feasible and so that's a wonderful
future for electronics but it's not the
one that we're interested in we're
interested in a different one that can
coexist with that kind of electronics
that addresses a different problem
statement where you essentially assume
that the transistors are already small
enough you already have enough of them
and they already switch at high enough
speeds but the problem is that all known
high performance electronics are built
on substrates that look like this so
this is a mono crystalline silicon wafer
diced into various sizes it's a
wonderful platform for doing
high-performance silicon integrated
circuits because the material base is
extremely pure this is a very fly
surface allows you to do very precise
manufacturing of the fine line
electrodes that are needed for the
devices and the interconnects and so on
but this platform offers up severe
design constraints because it has the
properties of a plate of glass
essentially it's rigid it's brittle it
fractures easily you can't bend it you
certainly can't stretch it it's also
completely planar in its geometry and
you have silicon everywhere even though
you really only need silicon at the
positions of the active devices and a
lot of an integrated circuit is not
necessarily the switching transistors
themselves so a wonderful platform for
conventional electronics but those kind
of geometrical and mechanical
constraints set by the wafer really
prevent you from doing kinds of things
that might be interesting and for
example if you could reformat
electronics into a shape that's stretchy
bendy curvilinear soft and it's
mechanical properties then you might be
able to do things that are impossible if
you're constrained to that kind of way
for platform and what are those things
you can imagine lots of things one of
some of the more pedestrian ones would
be you know a flexible display that has
the look and feel of a sheet of paper
but it's a conventional display in the
regular sense of the word or you can
imagine the ability to bring that kind
of soft curvy electronics to bear on
problems in human health by virtue of
the fact that if you have a tissue like
form of electronics then it can
intimately wrap and integrate with the
curvilinear soft tissues of the body in
a very natural and very powerful way she
might be able to build circuits that
actually integrate with the surface of
the body at the epidermis for example to
provide advanced health monitoring
functions you might build an integrated
circuit thing and wrap the curvilinear
soft surfaces of the brain to establish
a brain-machine interface or to do
Diagnostics on patients who suffer from
epilepsy Monitoring and also stimulation
delivered therapy in ways that be
impossible if you're constrained at this
kind of rigid brittle silicon based type
of electronics which is you know the
more
established technology that's out there
today so this is what we've referred to
as bio integrated opportunities for a
soft stretchable electronics but that's
not all there are other areas that we
think are also interesting where you
look to biology for a design inspiration
in engineered human sort of manmade
devices and the concept there is that
evolution has come up with all kinds of
solutions to very challenging problems
in technology but none of those problems
look like a silicon wafer in geometry or
mechanics and one good example is in the
mammalian eye where the detector surface
is actually hemispherical e curved and
that type of geometry much different
than a flat CCD chip that you'd find in
a digital camera you can buy today has
advantages because it allows a very wide
angle field of view with very simple
lens optics for doing the imaging so
this is a being example of electronic
eyeball camera man-made device that
receives inspiration from biology so
these are a couple of different areas
where we think breaking away from the
design constraints set by the silicon
wafer would open up new opportunities
and new ways to deploy semiconductor
devices and electronics and this talk
will really focus on these application
areas towards the end but before I get
there I need to step you through some of
the ideas that allow you to go from
planar brittle silicon wafer based
electronics to these tissue like bio
integrated systems that you see here
today and I'll show you physical
embodiments the devices that do exactly
that and this type of function so how do
you get there you might think that if
you want tissue like electronics you
probably have to move away from silicon
because silicon itself is a hard brittle
material and if you do that maybe you
need to go off and develop completely
new classes of electronic materials
maybe those that are based on carbon
nanotubes or polymers or elastomers or
other kinds of materials and that'd be
one way to go we've been interested in
that over the years so of a lot of other
groups I think there's a lot of promise
in that approach but from an engineering
standpoint you could make the claim that
if you can do things like this with
silicon then that's probably the
material set you would use because you
would be able to build on the incredible
base of scientific knowledge as it's
developed around silicon as a result of
the decade
long efforts around that material for
more conventional integrated circuits so
that's been kind of our approach to kind
of revisit silicon and think about it
from a mechanic's standpoint and figure
out whether it could be deployed for
these kind of bio integrated systems and
so it turns out that relatively simple
ideas and mechanics allow you go from
wafers to tissue like electronics now I
mentioned two features of silicon in
ultra-thin form on this slide so if you
think about a silicon wafer as I
mentioned before it very much does have
the properties of a plate of black glass
you can't bend it very much and if you
drop it it shatters so that's what one
reason why it has that mechanics is just
due to the intrinsic properties of the
silicon the other has to do with the
geometry of the wafer itself the wafers
that are used commercially these days
have about a thickness of maybe 1/2
millimeter or one one millimeter in
thickness and it's partly because of
that large thickness that it has this
resistance to bending and the inability
to bend regardless of how much force you
apply and if you think about taking that
silicon wafer and slicing it very very
very thin so take a silicon wafer and
create from it a silicon nano membrane
so a sheet of silicon where the
thickness of that silicon might be a
hundred nanometers instead of half a
millimeter and what happens is by
shrinking the thickness you decrease by
many orders of magnitude the resistance
to bending for an applied force and that
quantity is known as the bending
stiffness is proportional to the Young's
modulus the intrinsic properties of the
silicon times the thickness of the
silicon whether it's the wafer this nano
membrane raised to the third power and
that cubic dependence of the bending
stiffness on thickness really provides a
powerful Weaver for creating a flexible
form of silicon from something that you
typically sort of qualitatively think
about as an intrinsically brittle
material so in fact if you go from a
wafer scale thickness of silicon you
have the bending stiffness is about 10
Newton meters if you decrease the
thickness into this nano membrane regime
you can go from 10 Newton meters in
bending stiffness down to about 10 finto
Newton meters and that has a qualitative
impact on the mechanical characteristics
of material go from a plate of glass to
a floppy
essentially just by reducing the
thickness and the same concept you can
see if you know a 2x4 is rigid piece of
material a sheet of papers flexible it's
just by virtue of the fact that the
paper's flexible thin that it's flexible
it's the same material so the same idea
here very simple bending mechanics so
thin is floppy the other nice thing
about thin is that it's sticky in the
sense that if you take a sheet of
silicon like this and you print it down
onto a surface in this case we printed a
beam of silicon sort of delivered it to
a ridge that we've machined on to
another silicon wafer no adhesive here
it's just by virtue of Van der waals
very nonspecific adhesion forces that
keep this piece of silicon tethered to
the substrate at this one in to the
extent that you can keep this other part
of the silicon suspended in it kind of a
cantilever fashion and the reason why
the membranes stick so well to other
materials has to do with the fundamental
properties that drive crack propagation
between two materials that you bring
together in this way and in particular
the propensity for forming cracks
decreases if everything else has held
the same in the same geometry decreases
linearly with the thickness of the
material and in fact you know for
thermally driven crack formation where
the change in temperature of the system
is driving cracks typically differences
in coefficients the thermal expansion
will cause interface cracks to form but
the energy release rate associated with
opening of those cracks is decreasing
linearly with thickness that means the
energy release rate when you go from a
wafer to a Nano membrane form of silicon
decreases also by orders of magnitude
so ultra-thin silicon is floppy and it's
sticky
so it's floppy that means you can bend
it it's sticky which means you can take
the silicon and you can put it on to a
bendable substrate like a sheet of
plastic and not worry too much about
interface adhesion by virtue of this
linear scaling down in the energy
release rate associated with crack
formation so those are the interesting
aspects of ultra thin sheets of a
material like silicon how do you create
it in the first place and their variety
of ways to do this this gives one scheme
that applies to classes and we can
materials that are currently used in
lasers and photo detectors and wireless
radio communication devices it's gallium
arsenide in this case and it turns out
that you can grow this gallium arsenide
material on a gallium arsenide substrate
in a special way epitaxially in
particular that yields very high quality
material now if you do that kind of
growth strategy in a way that alternates
between aluminum arsenide and gallium
arsenide you can create a multi-layer
stack of this kind of material which is
the semiconductor material you want to
use in your devices separated by this
other material aluminum arsenide in this
case which isolates those sheets of
gallium arsenide for one another and the
nice thing about this kind of
multi-layer stack is that if you go
through and you etch down through the
thin films that you're growing to expose
the sidewalls and you immerse this in a
particular type of etchant in this case
hydrofluoric acid it will etch away the
aluminum arsenide selectively that is it
etches this material a factor of a
million times faster than this material
and so if you grow that multi-layer
stack you etch down you dip it in HF and
what you do is you release then from the
surface of the growth way for
multi-layer stacks of ultra thin sheets
of gallium arsenic and because you're
doing this in a way that doesn't consume
the way for the wafer is sort of
catalytic in this process you can come
back
use that wafer for another growth route
and really create enormous quantities of
semiconductor grade nano membranes in
this case made of this compound
semiconductor gallium arsenide which is
useful for high quality high-speed
electronics lasers LEDs and other other
kinds of devices so here's how that
looks in real life is cartoon it's works
extremely well here's an example of a 40
layer stack where we have 280 meter
thick sheets of gallium arsenide
separated by 20 nanometer thick layers
of aluminum arsenide each down through
that stack and then she immersed it in
this hydrofluoric acid that eliminates
the aluminum arsenide off pops a lot of
these gallium arsenide membranes into
the solution bath and then you can
deposit them down onto another surface
create bulk quantities of these kind of
nano membrane form semiconductor
materials and so each one of these
little squares of gallium arsenide sir
can serve as an active material
component of a wide range of devices in
Electronics and other kinds of systems
but if you look at this this is not
really a very good starting point for an
integrated circuit this is sort of a
disorganized collection of little
membranes so the question is if this is
your answer on the materials like how do
you grow semiconductor nano membranes it
creates another problem which is how do
you organize an international way to
build an integrated circuit where the
yields need to be 99.99% individual
devices so one way to do this is just
lift all the material off into the
etching bath and then use some kind of
strategic way to pattern the surface and
surface chemistry or relief structures
so that as this material sediments out
of the etching bath it drops down into
specially defined locations on a target
substrate thereby preparing that surface
for formation of interconnect wires to
build a functional system and that's an
interesting concept in what is sometimes
referred to as guided self-assembly
we're interested in that a lot of other
groups are interested in it as well I
think it's promising the problem is to
achieve the kind of engineering yields
you need for doing realistic things
extremely challenging so in parallel
with those kind of efforts we take a
slightly different tack which is that if
you're creating this material from a
wafer base source in the first place if
you can design the system so you
undercut at these nano membranes from
their underlying host substrate but
design lithographic structures so that
they remain tethered to the underlying
substrate in their lithographically
defined location then you can think of
that processed wafer as an inking pad in
a printing process that uses the soft
stamp to pop off of the surface of those
wafers selected collections of those
nano membranes there by inking them up
onto the surface of the stamp index the
stamp over this is all happening at room
temperature in open air and then deliver
that stamp down to a target substrate of
interest could be a sheet of plastic a
piece of rubber and drop off the Nano
membranes from the stamp onto this
target surface in sort of a massively
parallel fashion that allow you to come
back and do this in a step and repeat
type of mode to spread out this active
material in desired locations on a
foreign substrate you do this as many
times as you need
and then the next step in building
integrated circuit be why are these
individual membranes together to make
functional device and so that's an
approach that's worked extremely well
for us now if you think about how to
make it work reliably it's really all
about understanding the physics of
adhesion between those nano membranes in
the surface of the stamp because in
particular you want the adhesion be
strong enough you can pop them off the
surface of this inking pad with high
yields but you don't want it to be too
strong because you need to drop the
membranes off of a stamp down on to the
target surface surface where you want to
build your circuit so it all has to do
with how do you modulate the adhesion
strength from a low a high adhesion
value to a low adhesion value in a
reversible and controllable way and it
turns out their variety of biologically
inspired routes to doing that using
inspiration from gecko feet you can
exploit the viscoelastic nature of the
elastomer to accomplish that kind of
switching and I won't get into those
details we just mention that that
becomes the focus of the science in
making this engineering approach works
really understanding the physics of soft
adhesion so that you can manipulate the
adhesion strength on and off to
facilitate that process so you can build
a tool around that kind of concept we
work with management manufacturing
engineers in our department of
mechanical engineering you build a tool
like that there's a stamp here there's
an inking pads process wafer here
there's a two-stage to access stage that
supports a platform here of course ones
at Gen 3 display glass room and pick up
membranes here using a stamp in this
fixturing jig there's a camera that
allows you to look through the
transparent stamp so you can do
registration and alignment load cells
over here and it's all under computer
controls that this can happen with very
high throughput corresponding to sort of
about a million nano membranes moved per
hour with this kind of system with very
good overlay accuracy so this is what it
looks like if you run that tool use that
kind of concept create these nano
membranes from the ways that I showed
you before in this case it's an array of
gallium arsenide nano membranes created
in a densely packed configuration on a
source wafer and then spread out at low
aerial coverage in a step and repeat
printing mode onto a sheet of plastic
which is what you see here which is
subsequently wrapped around a
cylindrical glass support so each one of
these nano membranes is about 250
microns on the side
about the size of a human hair roughly
200 meters thick
and printed in this case is about 1600
of them with 100% yield so it's really
demonstrating very high levels of
control both in the process as well as
in control the adhesion for the assembly
so by virtue of the fact that the Nano
membranes are sticky they stay bonded to
the plastic they're flexible and floppy
so they can follow the curvature of the
plastic and it's bent state and that
provides a really exceptionally good
starting point for making high quality
electronics wafer quality electronics on
a bendable sheet of plastic and so I
won't go into all the details of how you
go about doing that just make the
argument have very high quality
semiconductor material on plastic you
can wire it up to make circuits and kind
of leave it at that
and you can make circuits that are
extremely flexible so I mentioned before
that as the thickness of a material goes
down it's bending rigidity goes down the
surface strains associated with bending
also go down they go down linearly with
thickness so if you take those very thin
membranes of semiconductors put them on
a very very thin sheet of plastic then
you can make an integrated circuit with
the properties of a comparably designed
wafer base device except that are
exceptionally flexible in this case
wrapped around the sharp edge of
coverslip this is a silicon CMOS
integrated circuit where the silicon
layers in this case are sitting on top
of a polymer sheet where we select the
polymer sheet to be very thin but not
arbitrarily thin because we design the
system so that the neutral mechanical
plane is coincident with the most
brittle layer in these circuits which
happened to be the silicon if you think
about the neutral mechanical plane it's
also a simple concept in mechanic's see
if this sheet of material and you bend
it in this way then the top surface is
in tension the bottom surface is in
compression for uniform material the
geometric midpoint c0 bend a new strain
and the neutral mechanical axis in this
system is not the geometric midpoint
that you compute where it is you overlap
that neutral playing with the brittle
silicon layer by choosing the underlying
plastic substrate with appropriate
thickness to do that so in this case the
entire circuit is just a little over one
and a half microns in thickness able to
bend a very sharp radii of curvature
about 25 microns in that case at the
same time you retain sort of wafer scale
characteristics and the individual
switching devices and the integrated
circuits you build with them so if you
look at the intrinsic mobility it's
about the same as what we see in a
comparably designed device on a silicon
wafer on/off ratio of contrast and
switching is very good you can achieve
very high frequency operation you with
very coarse Channel dimensions because
of this very good
intrinsic charge transport property of
mono crystalline silicon created in this
way so that's a good step towards bio
integration but it's not where you need
to go if you think of a sheet of plastic
you can bend it around a sharp edge like
that you can wrap a cylinder or a cone
but you can't even wrap a sphere much
less a curvilinear body part so you can
wrap developable surfaces but not
undeveloped opal ones and all of the
human body is an undeveloped opal
surface so flexible is not good enough
the body is curvilinear in a way that
you can't wrap with a sheet of plastic
and it's also stretchable in a way that
a plastic sheet cannot accommodate so
you need something that goes beyond
bendability
to real stretching capacity that is the
ability to accommodate large strain
deformation not just been induced
strains and so you might think thin
makes flexible how in the world are you
gonna get to stretchable and so we
thought that that was going to be a
daunting problem but it turns out that
that also has a very simple solution and
I won't get into all the details but
just kind of give you a qualitative
sense of it so if you take this very
thin silicon as I've argued it's very
flexible very bendable can be very tight
radius of curvature now you take that
silicon you bond it against a rubber
substrate that's slightly pre-stretched
after you bond it and you relax the pre
stretch that induces compressive
stresses in the bonded silicon and the
silicon when subjected to those kinds of
stresses on a soft elastomer substrate
will respond to that
by undergoing a spontaneous non-linear
buckling instability that yields silicon
in this wavy shape these are strips of
silicon about 180 meters thick 10
microns wide on an underlying silicon
rubber substrate after that kind of
process and you can see this very wavy
shape and the first time we saw there's
sort of by accident we thought fantastic
that's exactly what we want because now
we have sort of an accordion bellows
made out of silicon in the sense that if
you take that underlying substrate and
you stretch it out in this direction the
silicon strips can accommodate that
strain in sort of an end-to-end
displacement sense through changes in
the amplitude in the wavelength of the
waves so as you stretch it out like this
the amplitudes go down wavelengths go up
there's not much strain in the silicon
itself but you have an overall stretch
ability which is what you're after if
you compress it though the opposite
thing the amplitude goes up the
wavelength goes down so you can go back
and forth like that completely linear
elastic response to strain where the
modulus is dominated by the stiffness of
the underlying substrate the silicon
buckling physics allows it to move in a
way that can they can move with those
strains so it's very much accordion
bellows physics turns out that the
details are quite important to
understand because in these kinds of
systems the mechanics design becomes as
important to circuit design so we're
fortunate to be able to work with an
excellent theoretical mechanician at
Northwestern and we work with him to
develop a finite element modeling and
analytical models exactly where the
stresses and strains are in a system
like this and turns out it's
qualitatively different than an
accordion bellows but in terms of
thinking about the physics this is a
good model and we've sort of gone
through the details of that so in this
case this is just a concept it's applied
to strips of silicon that's not an
integrated circuit and in fact that is
not a good starting point for an
integrated circuit because it's
impossible to define the metal wiring on
a soft rubber substrate like that but
the same idea can be applied chip scale
so take a altra thin integrated circuit
like this bond it against a probe I
actually pre strain piece of rubber
relax the biaxial pre strain and now you
get it kind of a 2d buckling pattern the
forms it's a lot more complicated than
what I showed you before but
conceptually it's very similar so in
this case it's an array of ten CMOS ring
oscillators three stage there's some
inverters down here and isolated in and
p-channel transistors up here it's
illuminated in a way that sort of
highlights the way the structure that
forms as a result of that process so you
can imagine if you stretch this thing in
any direction like that those wave
structures can change their geometries
to accommodate that overall deformation
without fracturing the silicon or the
other
components of the circuit and so you
have an overall an integrated system
that has is dominated by the mechanics
of the underlying rubber so it's soft
stretchy it's able to accommodate
curvilinear deformations in ways that
suggest an ability to integrate with the
human body
now here's an image that was taken by
photographers at our Beckman Institute
it's sort of nice in an aesthetic sense
but it also illustrates the physics so
we dropped off one of these wavy
integrated circuits they took a glass
pipette plunge it down the middle and
what you see is that at localized force
causes this kind of deformation in the
circuit where you end up with these
curvilinear contours and even see this
interconnect line which was originally
wavy and buckled in its shape like this
one back here has now been stretched out
into a flat state to accommodate the
tensile strains associate at that local
force so you can also imagine if you
push this a little bit part of that line
would probably break because it's been
pulled flat it can't come accommodate
much additional strain so there's sort
of a range of stretch ability in these
systems is about 15 to 20 percent I'll
come back to that in a second so what
are the properties of these things look
like this looks like you know you've
taken a perfectly fine and graded
circuit and kind of crumpled it up maybe
destroyed it in some way but it turns
out that the waves are fairly modest in
their amplitude few microns in amplitude
200 microns in period so the actual
strains and the materials are modest and
as a result if you probe the individual
devices is it being Illustrated here or
the integrated circuit the performance
of this kind of device is pretty much
similar to the comparably dot design
flat geometry so you've achieved the
mechanics you want you wanted without
sacrificing any of the performance now
there are a couple of disadvantages and
I've already mentioned one one is
limited range of stretchability so you
can stretch these about 15 to 20 percent
in a practical sense before things start
to break and that's just a constraint
associated with the physics of buckling
the other disadvantage is that these
devices are not fully isolated from
strain so as you stretch this thing
around the silicon is experiencing some
amount of strain and strain actually
changes the way that the device is
operated by modest amount 15 to 20
percent and that's not important for a
lot of the applications we're interested
in but if you're imagining building a
very sophisticated integrated circuit
that might be a problem
isolation and strain range are our two
limitations of this design and both of
them flow out and the fact that you're
really at the mercy of buckling physics
you really haven't engineered where that
wave structure has formed
that's just determined by the nonlinear
mechanics of buckling and so the way to
avoid those constraints is to bring to
bear better engineering control on that
buckling process and the way that you
can do that involves two steps one is
taking the circuit and etching away
parts of the material in the substrate
you don't really need it's no device
there's no device there you can just
edge that into an open hole so the
circuit takes on the layout of a mesh
and open mesh and furthermore you design
specifically which part of that mesh
bonds with the underlying rubber
substrate not everything should bond if
you want to optimize the system just
selected locations you can do that by
tailoring in a pattern way the surface
chemistry if you do those two things
they need to make systems that look more
like this
so this is just a test platform it's an
array of silicon nano membrane Islands
connected by polymer metal interconnect
bridges that adopt this kind of non
coplanar arc shape design so the entire
system is in an open mesh the nodes of
the match correspond to silicon where
you can imagine you know populating
those regions with devices and then the
interconnects in the mesh are not bonded
strongly be the underlying elastomer and
as a result when you relax that initial
priests rein they pop up delaminate and
pop up out of the plane and so if you do
that you can create circuits that you
can stretch maybe one hundred two
hundred percent much more like a rubber
band
piece of latex or spandex for example
and you do it in a way that really
strain isolates the silicon these
silicon islands don't see much strain at
all because the strain is being
accommodated by these bridge shaped
interconnect ribbons essentially and so
what these images are showing is you can
take a circuit like that and now you can
sort of wrap it on any kind of surface
you want and this was just a demo we
took a this silicon integrated circuit
and wrapped it on the dimpled surface of
a golf ball you can see that kind of
golf ball shape and you might imagine
there could conceivably the applications
of silicon electronics on a golf ball
and a lot of people have approached
just with ideas about that but we're not
interested in that kind of application
but it does suggest an ability to take
silicon and put it on the brain for
example which is also a highly curved
linear surface just like that
to bring to bear to problems in
neuroscience the full integrated power
of silicon electronics and that's what
I'll talk to you for the rest of the
talk about so if you think about your
bio integration of electronics with the
body that field has a very long history
4050 years people been thinking about
putting electrodes on the body
you know shocking tissues burning it out
jacking current measuring things about
the body and there are a number of
products that are already out there
fda-approved for various things deep
brain stimulators for example to treat
certain forms of Parkinson's disease
pacemakers of course cochlear implants
to restore hearing loss all kinds of
things but if you look at all of the
active electronics devices that are out
there today they incorporate this kind
of design so this is the example brain
stimulator same thing for pacemaker or
cochlear implant all the other stuff
it's basically a separate box of
conventional silicon wafer based
electronics at one position wires that
run out of that box and then terminate
at a few electrode point contacts of the
tissue in this case these are wires that
plunge down into the brain and then the
voltages that are pulsed onto those
wires is controlled in a sophisticated
way with the electronics back here and
although that can address certain
problems in human health it's a pretty
primitive design when you think about
it's not a very intimate integration you
have very limited numbers of electrode
contacts that you can accommodate and
the electrode and the electronics are
totally separated a more appealing way
to do things might be to use design
strategies that you know our president
contact lens where the material itself
is mechanically and shaped matched to
the tissue it's gas and water permeable
it integrates in a very natural way but
the problem is it's not active there's
no electronics here
so basically reformat the electronics
look more like this for important
problems either on or in the surface
surfaces of the human body and so one of
the most compelling places to think
about introducing that
technology is at the neural interface of
the brain you think in a brain it's a
very advanced electrical system and if
you want to study its function or you
want to perform therapy on it or monitor
its function the you know ideal thing
would be to bring to bear to that
problem man's most sophisticated form of
electronics was the silicon integrated
circuits and as I've mentioned many
times there's a huge mismatch in
geometry obvious one also mechanics and
I mentioned a couple times only just
emphasizes so the modulus the stiffness
of the silicon itself is about 150 Giga
Pascal the modulus of brain tissue is
about 5 kilopascal so huge difference in
geometry that also in mechanics and so
you know what do people do today one
thing they do is build devices that look
like this these are Utah raised very
sophisticated device has been used to
advantage in neuroscience for the last
15 maybe almost 20 years spectacular
piece of technology it basically
involves a flat platform where you can
integrate silicon integrated electronics
just take a chip out of that way for
bonded up on here and then establish
electrical contacts between that
integrated circuit and shafts of
micromachines
silicon electrodes that penetrate into
the brain so you take you put your
circuit there and you take this thing
and then you mount it into the brain
with an air hammer and these pins
penetrate down into the tissue the tips
of these pins establish the electrical
contact to the brain tissue and then you
do stuff you know you you study brain
function you develop a brain machine
interface in that way and that's fine
provided you're not doing on a human
this is this and maybe it's not even
fine you do it on primates anyway this
is what's done and you know obviously
you're sort of doing some damage when
you inject this thing into the brain
that's kind of an obvious one the other
ones not so obvious which is that these
are still shards of very high modulus
150 gigapascal material against 5
kilopascal very soft brain tissue and
the problem with that is that the brain
is a dynamic system it swells it
contracts it moves around in the head a
little bit and so that causes the soft
tissue to rattle up against the
very rigid silicon shards and that
causes irritation over time and
continued degradation so these things
don't have long life times when when
mounted up so it's been a great research
tool it's fantastically powerful thing
and will continue to be very useful but
we're hoping if the future looks a bit
different where you create this kind of
electronics to look like the tissue in
shape and mechanics the soft shape
conformal biocompatible the thing
integrates in a very natural way and
provides an intimate interface in that
in that manner using the kinds of ideas
and mechanics materials and assembly
techniques I described to you up to this
point so we've been working on that
class the device last two and a half
three years with experts at the pin
epilepsy Center University of
Pennsylvania's Medical School they have
experts in this area clinicians who
actually do surgical procedures to treat
acute cases of epilepsy so this is what
they do and we're trying to convince me
discovering tools for neuroscience is
something that can have clinically
relevant mode of use in surgical
operation and so this is what's done
today again very acute cases patients
skull cap is removed surgically it's
froze brain and then you laminate on the
surface of the brain these very crude
electrode structures are basically solid
metal pads embedded in a silicone rubber
sheet either in the form of a strip or a
2d sheet like this each electrode has a
separate wire that comes out this way
the patient is only under local
anaesthetic so there are wait while this
is happening all these wires are coming
off of the head and then running to a
computer and what is done is a
neurotoxin is applied to the patient to
artificially stimulate a physical
seizure and at the same time you're
measuring electrical activity at each of
these electrode pads which are fairly
coarsely spaced about a centimeter on a
centimeter like that kind of resolution
and you can't handle very much more
because you have to deal with all these
wires it just becomes too cumbersome to
continue to add electrodes but if you do
that then a trained surgeon can tell
from this spatio-temporal pattern of
electrical activity recorded in this way
which part of the brain is most
intimately tied to the physical seizure
and once that's done
this thing is peeled away and you go in
with a scalpel essentially cut it out
the aberrant region and so in that kind
of procedure we are told that one would
want and it sort of makes sense the
highest possible resolution in that
mapping because you want to pinpoint the
region of the brain that has to be
resected you don't want to take away any
more than absolutely necessary the idea
is to go from electrodes to full
integrated electronic in this kind of
format for that sort of sort of
procedure and so with the ideas that I
described before you can really ramp up
levels of integration very very
sophisticated system so this is an
example of a 288 point measurement
device we're doing that kind of
procedures over two thousand these nano
membrane transistors it consists of an
array of thin electrode pads on a
flexible sheet these laminate just
directly to the surface of the brain
they don't penetrate in it's just water
capillarity sort of keeps this thing
adhere to the tissue almost like a piece
of saran wrap on a piece of meat for
example each sensor has a multiplexing
transistor and a local amplifier to
boost up the signal levels it's actually
device designed for cardiac but the
neural one is very very similar this is
what it looks like these devices not
only have to have nice mechanics but
they also have to operate when
completely immersed in salt water
because when you open up the the head
and expose the brain dries out so
occasionally you have to flood the thing
with warm saline so your circuit cannot
short out into the tissue when that
happens very bad things will happen in
the brain if that occurs so thing needs
to be perfectly encapsulated and
waterproof that turns out to be a really
practical difficulty because you need to
do that without sacrificing the
mechanics you need a waterproof layer
that's thin enough that you maintain the
mechanical flexibility so won't go into
the details of that that can be done so
these things operate when completely
immersed in salt water for extended
periods so let me show you an example of
device data that comes out of this kind
of experiment performed on a cat Bob so
there's a colony of epileptic cats at
University of Pennsylvania as you go
through this exact same steps that I've
mentioning before open the skull in this
case it's not electrodes it's full
integrated electronics placed on the
brain apply a neurotoxin
stimulate a seizure and watch what's
going on here at very very high
resolution in terms of time in space so
let me show you a movie what comes out
of that so this is what it looks like so
this is a spacial temporal map this
distance along one axis to that tape
other axis here this is a representative
time trace of a single sensor in that
array as a function of time the
neurotoxin is applied here there's a lot
of abnormal activity going on right now
but the physical seizure has not set in
that doesn't happen until about a second
and a half after administering the drug
if you talk to people who suffer from
epilepsy this is a common thing they can
kind of sense that a seizure is coming
on before it actually happens and you
can actually see that for the first time
in this kind of measurement now the
seizure is in full-swing and if you look
at the level of periodicity in the
response of a single point in this
electrode array it's quite remarkable
and that's reflected by this recurring
spiral wave instability that you see
across the across the area and so this
kind of measurement is unprecedented
never been done in a live animal model
before because silicon electronics
doesn't integrate with the surface of a
cat brain for example so it's been done
in brain slices ex vivo but not in a
live animal model like this so I think
it's going to provide a lot of insights
in the fundamental neuroscience of
epilepsy we're excited about that but I
think the more important thing for us is
it has this clinical mode abuse as well
and this kind of resolution can't be
achieved with those passive electrode
arrays so this is one thing that you can
do now that was impossible previously by
virtue of these simple ideas and
mechanics materials and assembly that
I've been describing to you you can also
do really wild stuff so you can take
these sheets and you can wrap them
around a soft insert now you can plunge
them down into hidden surfaces the brain
see the gap between the right and left
hemispheres into the soul side of the
brain so really do high-resolution
mapping on surfaces that are totally
inaccessible using other approaches
until we publish some initial results in
that kind of capability as well so again
as a discovery tool I think it's very
very powerful and we're working with
experts in this
area to try to do something of value let
me shift gears for the last part of the
talk last ten minutes or so and talk to
you about another point of integration
so brain monitors it's great is pretty
much just for hospital use right now and
so if you want to develop a technology
that's more widely adopted all by the
general public you know the skin becomes
an interesting integration point skins
tough it's interesting kind of material
its soft curvilinear has you know all
the kinds of challenges that the brain
has in many ways but additionally so if
you think about what's out there today
in terms of skin monitoring electronic
devices it uses the same basic design
principle I outlined previously
point-contact electrodes connected to
external boxes of electronics in this
case the electrodes are affixed against
the skin with an adhesive tape plus a
conductive gel to facilitate low low
contact resistance coupling to the skin
because you have a wire going to each of
these electrode pads you can only
accommodate a few otherwise just the you
know practical difficulties of wires
becomes challenging so that's one
constraint the other constraint is
nobody wants to wear this because this
is uncomfortable it's irritating to the
skin it's not you know something is
painful but it's almost like Chinese
water torture it means the kind of thing
is just great it creates an incredible
irritation over time so it's great for
maybe a clinical use but nobody wants to
wear that continuously you know during
during the day so it's great for some
applications others not the slightly
more advanced way to do things is take
that box crack it open pull out the
microchips glue them to a tape and then
take the you know device to the skin
like that and you can do that's maybe a
little bit better but still the
mechanics of the tape or not matched to
the tissue again flexible is not
matching the properties of the skin and
so as a result it's an irritating Eirik
interface and you know people would
rather not wear something like that
either so the skin is a unique system in
the body it provides our exclusive
sensory interactions for a tactile
interaction with the environment and
it's time dynamic and structurally
complex in a way that the brain in the
heart for example is not the modulus of
the different layers in the skin very
with death this is time to
and it's a cellular escalator and since
cells start here they differentiate up
to the stratum corneum and then they
exfoliate off the thickness varies
across the body and you still have this
curvilinear low modulus challenge to
deal with and it's really these
characteristics that make it non-trivial
to integrate even electrodes much less
electronics with the skin it's been
historically a difficult problem so it's
hard to achieve
you know the interface is a problem
long-term viability with access and he's
and is always a problem nothing sticks
without irritation mechanics in shape or
never match and of course you have to
worry about cause power weight size that
kind of thing so we've been thinking
about that problem for about three years
with this kind of vision which is you
know a kid's temporary tattoo integrates
with the skin in a really nice way it's
completely mechanically and invisible it
sticks it's low cost it goes on a really
simple way it moves with the natural
motions of the skin it's completely non
constraining an emotion of course it's
not electronics but what would it take
to make electronics that look like that
if you think about the geometry and the
mechanics of a kid's temporary tattoo
very very thin by micron ultralight
maybe a milligram per centimeter squared
very low modulus match to the epidermis
ideally but as low as you can go by
kilopascal might be a good target you
know having some air and water
permeability at the same time as
achieving waterproof construction on the
electronics you want air and water
permeability in the regions of the
electronics that won't short out due to
the presence of water so it's a little
bit heterogeneous in terms of the
waterproofing but those are the kinds of
things that you would ideally like to
happen so you know can't can you do that
kind of thing and you know if you do
what is the key advantage I think the
key advantage is the fact that it goes
on it's mechanically invisible and by
virtue of the fact that driving the
thickness of the module is down to the
levels that are comparable to the skin
you sort of solve the adhesion problem
almost automatically without addressing
challenges and new adhesives to the skin
and you can see that I will go through
the details here this gets a little bit
gory but if you do mechanics modeling of
a sheet of epidermal electronics on the
skin and ask what happens
the interface between that electronics
in the skin when the skin is stretched
or bid you can compute the shear
stresses at the interface and the
peeling stresses that tend to drive
delamination of the electronics off the
skin and you can compare calculations
for silicon chip sheet of plastic and
skin like construction what you find is
that when you enter this low modulus
simultaneously with low thickness regime
you drive those interface straights
stresses down to very close to zero
factor of a million smaller than what
what you what you have to struggle with
if you try to bond a silicon chip to the
skin and so that becomes a very very
powerful feature of the mechanics and it
really drives the design of the
electronics into this sort of epidermal
modulus match regime and you can kind of
see that physics here so if you just
take a sheet of rubber and laminate it
to the surface of the skin you can see
the effects of thickness and mod and
modulus even when the materials are
exactly the same so this is on the arm
of a postdoc as a sheet of the silicon
rubber here it is laminated and then the
wrist is being contracted like that you
can see you start driving delamination
at the edges the thing just place the
flexible flakes off if you stretch it
like this again edge initiated
delamination the sheet comes off if you
do the same experiment though same
material just a slightly different
formulation so it's softer and thinner
then even without any adhesive at all
this is just laminated just van der
Waals forces against the skin it's
bonded very robustly you stretch it as
ha hard as you want it doesn't come to
you laminated and you can and you can
flex and move move your wrist without
causing causing the thing to peel off
and so it turns out you can look at that
in a very quantitative way and you can
develop models for how that interface
mechanics work and I won't step you
through that now if you have arrived at
a material that works in this way the
question is how do you get a circuit on
top of that without mechanically
stiffening the system in a way that
destroys that favorable mechanics and it
really comes back to ideas that I've
already articulated but implemented in
and really extreme what
so thin wavy buckled open mesh but in
this case in the design of a filamentary
serpentine structure so very very thin
devices and structures in this kind of
mash bonded a very low modulus elastomer
if you do that in create an integrated
circuit that has that characteristic and
then if you measure the stress-strain
response you find that this kind of
circuit can be very quantitatively
matched to the mechanical modules of the
skin this is a pig skin actually here so
160 kilopascal and for this circuit
stretch along that direction or along
that direction the modulus is almost
identical up to strains about 20% then
actually the module of the circuit is
lower than that of the skin but skin
starts to tear above 20% strain and you
do all the FE end modeling so you know
exactly what the peak material strains
are and that kind of design you can
manage that effective way now the key
thing is you can build all of your
devices in that wavy snake-like geometry
so you can cut your silicon light back
you can make a transistor that's in this
funny geometry it still works fine you
can create strain gauges even solar
cells photo detectors temperature
sensors you know capacitors inductors LC
oscillators all kinds of components can
be configured into that type of type of
platform and so if you take that thing
you laminate them on the skin then it
forms a very robust mechanical interface
and in a form that naturally moves with
the skin as its deformed so this is the
postdoc you did the work applied it here
and then we poked them in the skin this
pipette and kind of see it move like
that now if you peel this thing off this
is what it looks like
ultra thin floppy very tissue like and
so you can't manipulate it's just too
floppy and thin so the question is how
do you you know even handle this thing
in order to mount it on the skin in the
first place and the way that we do that
is just go back to kids temporary
tattoos which oftentimes involve a water
soluble backing layer so we use PVA in
this case laminate the epidermal
electronics on top of that then you can
use the PVA as a handle slap it on the
skin and then wash off the PVA just
leaving the epidermal electronics on the
I'll show you a movie of that process
here you see it so there's the piece
that's a PVA is facing outward the
silicon the epidermal electronics is on
the PVA and it's being pressed against
the skin and what the postdoc is doing
is they're just rubbing a thin layer of
water against the PVA gradually
dissolving it away leaving only the
epidermal electronics pressed directly
against the skin left behind
now what this circuit is it's really
just a demonstration or a test platform
consisting of array of silicon
transistors and inductive coil an RF
antenna their LC oscillators strain
gauges temperature gauges silicon diodes
as well so all the building blocks I
think for a sophisticated form of
electronics with integrated sensors
although it's not wired up to provide
sort of system level functionality it's
just a demonstration platform for those
components so once it's mounted up in
that way its epidermal and it's
mechanics and thickness and so when you
deform the skin you'll see that that
circuit moves naturally in a way that
really doesn't perturb it all the way
the skin is moving around so you look at
the way that skin is moving right into
regions adjacent that the circuits about
the same is where the circuit is located
so it's really you know by controlling
geometry and layout we can embed very
very rigid materials into an overall
platform that has mechanics matched to
the skin again in this case there's no
adhesive between the electronics and the
skin this is one way to do it I think
for more robust integration you may want
to add an adhesive but this is just a
demonstration showing that by
controlling the mechanics you can really
drive the stresses that would ordinarily
lead to the lamination down to very low
value so because there is no adhesive
you just peel it back and so that's
what's happening now you see peeling
away and circuits coming away this is
just death dead parts of the or unused
parts of the substrate
comes away so if I Keeling away dead
skin after you get sunburned means it's
a little disgusting at some level that's
what it is so this is not multiple use
at least in this way and then the sort
of fun thing you can actually use a
temporary tattoo as a substrate that's
nice because it's already a commercial
low-cost platform so you put electronics
there this is a this is a custom tattoo
actually this is the UIUC pirate like
the only way has nothing to do with
pilots but we can't use the chief
anymore so we got to go with pirates
these days do you apply it you peel it
back now the circuit is still there you
can't see it because the tattoo is not
as opaque so the circuit is sandwiched
in between the tattoo and the and the
skin and so that the electronics is
roughly coincident with the facial
region of this Illinois pirate and
you'll be able to see how that how that
moves as the skin is as the skin is
deform and again because the circuit is
designed carefully in terms of mechanics
the geometry it's not changing way the
tattoo or the underlying skin is moving
as a result of applied stresses and
strength so the sort of circuit is there
let me just as soon as this squeezes I'm
gonna skip skip on by this
I can deform it so let's see that second
okay so fine do you can see that it's
not it's not changing so this is another
experiment I mean that's sort of static
that formation we have very high-speed
camera at Beckman Institute so we
laminated this on a postdoc and they
took a screwdriver and hid his skin
right here the postdoc wasn't fat she
actually had to hit pretty hard in order
to create a stress wave to come across
that tattoo but looking at the dynamics
turned out to be sort of fun I was told
that this was a painful but anyway moves
up and down it's moving with the skin in
a dynamic in a static way without
without any problem so the interface
mechanics is great she can imagine doing
all kinds of electronics on the on the
skin I think the most compelling
applications are electronics that are
talking to the body through the skin so
it's really you know not only a mechanic
but also the electrical interface so
here's a confocal image of that
serpentine mesh to the crossing point
and you can see how it conforms to the
rough surface of the skin the skin is
incredibly rough it's a difficult place
to mount electronics for that reason
alone forgetting about the modulus in
the shape but you can you can do that
and so we have procedures now that allow
mounting sort of on the timescale of a
week or so and so I actually have a
couple of these things mounted up on my
arm right now and I'll show you what
these devices look like because I have a
really cool thing which is a little
portable microscope so we'll see how
this works so that's my bare skin and no
I'm not a lizard that's the way your
skin looks up close like that and so
I've had these things on for a few days
I wasn't into body art but now I'm
totally into body oh come on wearing
this stuff so this is uh this is a
region of the circuit can look at
different pads electrodes
conductors things like that
very conformal to the roughness and the
skin so this is Gen 1 this is what was
published in August but just as Moore's
law has a scaling trend we have our own
scaling trend where smaller is better
because the mechanics not necessarily
because we're interested in high-speed
transistors so we can go much smaller
now so this is actually much finer
features you have to look a little bit
closer but you can see that's that
filamentary serpentine mash fully
conformal to the skin the width of both
lines about 10 microns you kind of see
it the edge there the edge of the skin
and then you can see the electron that's
kind of following that you know tortuous
POG rafi so these things are quite
robust you take showers with these
things on there's no no problem so if
you're interested in taking a closer
look just my arm so so it's mostly
useful because I think you get an
interface to the body like you put your
cell phone on here but I don't think
that would be very interesting it's
really a sort of medical application and
so we've demonstrated that you can do a
CG you can measure heart rate heartbeat
even the detailed QRS patterns very high
quality measurements you can measure
EMGs electrical activity associate with
muscle motion if you compare the signal
the noise with conventional paste on gel
based wire electrode it's pretty
comparable but here you have full
electronics you can do you know
densities of electrodes to you know
arbitrarily high values have a lot of a
lot of advantages in that sense you can
also measure brainwave so we take this
device you do the chest you measure ECG
do the arm do you measure EMG put it on
the forehead and you can do EEG and so
this the details here are not that
important it basically just
characteristic brain activity that you
expect to see with a normal EEG system
you can measure it here one of the
interesting things is that there's
sufficient data content in the EMG
traces eg as well to form the basis of a
primitive brain machine
human machine interface so this is an
example we took one of these epidermal
EMG measuring system put on a neck again
it can go on the neck you don't even
know it's there and then you can measure
the electrical activity as you non
vocally state different words so you
just mouthed different different words
and you can create this kind of data set
this is a frequency spectrogram of EMG
measured in this way this is time along
the x-axis and you can see there are
characteristic differences between
different words and we worked with Todd
Coleman whose signal processing guy in
ECE at Illinois
basically developed pattern recognition
algorithm value take this data and then
pin it into a finite vocabulary of words
so this is just a baby step in that
direction so we can do four words we do
up-down left-right but for someone who's
suffering from a disease of larynx or
otherwise physically impaired maybe this
begins to hinted a way to do you know
human-machine interfaces and you know
you think about prosthetic control and
disabled people my students were mostly
interested in playing video games so
we've demonstrated the strategy game
because it's all the pattern recognition
that integrated in software so it's not
fast enough to do you know shoot them up
but you can do up strategy and you move
this cursor up-down left-right just
using neck muscles to to control the
interface so I think you know interfaces
of that sort are interesting but let me
just conclude the talk with one sort of
final image that you can take home with
you if you which is another way these
devices can be used to give measure
muscle activity but you can also
stimulate so it's a two-way thing so you
can do both at the same time you have a
epidermal device on the forearm for
example you can measure muscle
contractions there you can also
stimulate them and then that becomes
interesting for physical rehabilitation
so we work with researchers john
mcdonald and others at johns hopkins
university explore that capability so
you know epidermal electronics on muscle
it's not constraining motion to follow
it and you can do this kind of
stimulation in a feedback mode so if you
want to cure a muscle that's atrophied
for example sort of stimulate it that
might be interesting so this is a first
animal experiment demonstrating that
it's an SSI rat shaved hindquarters this
is a piece
a very primitive actually piece of
epidermal electronics this is initial
demo that's stimulating the fine muscle
quarters and also measuring EMG at the
same same time so you can do some kind
of interesting things in control and
this is just very recent work but just
to show that it's possible so this
device is moving with the muscle it's
causing the muscle to move and it's
monitoring that as well so you see this
sort of move back and forth and this
looks pretty primitive it's not quite as
primitive as it may look because there's
actually rotation right there and then a
large scale deflection and so we're
controlling those two types of motions
by controlling the voltage and current
impulse on these different electrodes
and measuring the thing in closed closed
loops like so this is this is a
direction I think could be could be
quite interesting where you're doing
both stimulation so with that let me
just go ahead and conclude and try to
give you a sense of why we think this is
an interesting area and what is
appealing to us about it is that it
really combines basic science with
engineering in a way that that could
lead the things that are useful to
people that's that's our hope anyway and
they're all kind of topics I think that
are out there that are you know really I
think this is just very early days
nothing nothing is really solved here in
the sense that no materials and
chemistry and physics and how you do an
Asian control for the assembly and the
mechanics and how do you think about the
biotic abiotic interface in these
systems it's active or pass there's a
lot of things that can be done here in
basic science but you know if you have a
successful outcome here it can map
immediately into engineered systems that
exploit that knowledge and advanced
surgical devices I'll show you a couple
things in neuro we do a lot on cardiac
health monitors wellness indicators and
then longer term you know implants BCI
and prosthetics control as well so with
that let me just conclude by
acknowledging some senior collaborators
work a lot of different folks I think
it's been key for us over the years
Mechanics manufacture
you know interphase chemical engineering
but the key is trying to work with
clinical folks so they can identify the
problems better than we ever could
Brian lid and neurology Dave Cowens
Marshall EPI and cardiology John
McDonald I mentioned you birth month
also an expert in cardiology so we try
to work on problems that they've
identified as serious ones from a
clinical standpoint so sort of maximize
utility of what we're doing but it
doesn't mean we have to work with those
guys and we have to work in their
environment which is kind of a new one
for us so this is March life means that
a key supporter involve a lot of the
cardiac work one of the world's most
prominent interventional cardiologists
Sarver Heart Center at University of
Arizona and this is part of his team and
you know this is the kind of world they
they operate in so we deliver devices to
them and they use them in the commercial
channel we're trying to make make this
stuff real and get it out there in a
form that people can use people like
Mars can use over time the key thing is
really outstanding students and you know
we're fortunate Illinois to have a lot
of them a lot of standing students here
but very very hardworking students and
postdocs I want to conclude by
acknowledging them and you know
acknowledge you for your attention I'd
be happy to answer questions if you have